et puis on en parle tout de suite avec
Diane Bellemare qui est sénatrice
indépendante économiste spécialiste des
questions de plein emploi c'est un
plaisir de vous retrouver madame
Bellemare bonsoir bonsoir moi de même
Gérald alors Jack meeting a-t-il raison
de dire qu'il faut revoir le mandat de
la Banque du Canada vous savez ma
réponse c'est oui en effet vous savez à
quel point je pense que le Canada
devrait adopter un mandat dual comme
d'autres pays comme la Nouvelle-Zélande
comme l'Australie par exemple comme les
États-Unis et donc au Canada on a cette
particularité d'avoir une loi de la
Banque du Canada qui est très vieille
elle a été revue une fois de temps en
temps sur le plan administratif mais
dans la loi là il y a un grand préambule
qui dit que la banque doit s'occuper de
prospérité de stabilité des prix de
bien-être d'emploi mais il y a pas un
mandat précis et c'est l'entente qui
fait foi demanda précis donnés à la
banque et quand vous êtes mandat dual
c'est à dire qu'on s'occupe de stabilité
des prix mais on s'occupe également de
façon égale
de l'emploi du marché du travail
exactement monsieur Filion Pascal en
quelque part dépendamment de commenter
la source de l'inflation il faut prendre
des bons instruments la politique
monétaire est un outil extrêmement
puissant et quand on l'utilise et qu'on
joue avec les taux d'intérêt ça a un
impact dans tous les marchés dans tous
les secteurs dans toutes les maisons du
Monde au Canada qui voit leur taux de
d'hypothèque et d'autres paiements
augmentés alors c'est très puissant
comme instrument quand on a une
inflation par la demande là la politique
monétaire elle est appropriée mais quand
on a une inflation par l'offre par les
chaînes d'approvisionnement comme nous
connaissons actuellement c'est un outil
qui faut manœuvrer avec beaucoup de
doigtés parce qu'en quelque part il peut
y avoir un effet rebond en utilisant la
hausse des taux d'intérêt pour
couper l'inflation la hausse des taux
d'intérêt à un impact comme vous savez
sur les prêts hypothécaires mais aussi
sur les loyers éventuellement et aussi
dans les investissements ça a un effet
de ralentissement dans l'investissement
donc est-ce que est-ce que la banque la
bonne politique en ce moment est-ce que
la banque est trop agressive est-ce
qu'on augmente trop les taux d'intérêt
comment vous voyez la situation bon à
mon avis c'est sûr qu'il fallait
éventuellement augmenter les taux
d'intérêt mais je pense qu'ils
augmentent trop rapidement pas
nécessairement au bon moment ils
auraient fallu qu'il les augmente quand
on allait très bien quand l'économie
elle est bien progressivement mais là
dans le contexte actuel où il y a
beaucoup d'incertitudes où on a beaucoup
d'investissements à faire aussi la
hausse des taux d'intérêt devrait être
beaucoup plus lente et progressive et on
devrait s'appuyer également sur la
politique fiscale pour contrer les
effets de l'inflation en même temps même
la banque a reconnu avoir tardé à agir
avoir fait des erreurs on a l'impression
que les banques centrales n'ont plus le
choix aujourd'hui est-ce que est-ce que
vous pensez qu'elles ont un peu perdu le
contrôle de l'inflation moi je ne crois
pas monsieur Fillon on a au Comité des
banques actuellement on est en train
d'étudier l'état de la santé de
l'économie du Canada et c'est encore
courant de dire que l'inflation est
temporaire mais avec une politique de
taux d'intérêt agressif on risque de
rendre l'inflation permanente à cause de
ses effets rebonds alors actuellement là
comme vous savez c'est sûr que les prix
augmentent mais vous-même vous en avez
fait des reportages sur la hausse des
prix des coûts des aliments y a-t-il
assez de concurrence sur les marchés
actuellement il y a d'autres mesures
qu'il faut mettre à profit pour freiner
l'inflation actuellement qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du travail de Tif muclé mais
de la Banque du Canada en ce moment face
à cette inflation les gens de voir
demain pour l'instant j'ai trouvé que je
l'ai rencontré à quelques reprises c'est
un homme qui écoute qui est assez
modérée
mais là je pense c'est assez il fallait
l'augmenter un peu mais j'espère qu'il
ne
osera pas les taux jusqu'à 4% parce que
vous savez ça sera des grosses
augmentations pour le Canada et ça
risque vraiment de créer une récession
et quand on compare ce que la banque
fait à ce qui se fait ailleurs dans le
monde ben les taux là ils vont être
beaucoup plus élevés que dans le reste
des autres pays si on augmente pas si on
arrêtait d'augmenter les taux avec une
inflation qui baisse très peu
présentement est-ce que pas un danger
que l'inflation se réemballe et qu'on
soit obligé d'adopter un remède de
cheval encore plus dur avec une
récession encore plus importante ensuite
moi je ne crois pas je pense qu'on a on
était supposé avoir appris de la période
inflationniste d'une inflation par les
coûts dans les années 76 80 puis tout ça
ça a duré longtemps le Canada a été
appris à ce moment-là d'une politique
monétaire très agressive ce que d'autres
pays ont pas fait autant
nous comme résultat mais on a eu des
taux de chômage élevés pendant longtemps
puis une inflation aussi importante donc
à mon avis il faut faire attention avec
la politique monétaire il faut laisser
faire le temps là des prix de continuer
à baisser il faut pas en remettre via
l'effet rebond comme je le disais tantôt
puis il faut essayer de voir à avoir un
peu plus de concurrence dans plusieurs
démarches et utiliser la politique
fiscale s'il faut freiner la demande
madame Bellemare c'est très intéressant
merci de cette analyse ce soir et de vos
propos sur la Banque du Canada c'est moi
qui vous remercie au revoir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI